sorry Frank I can't make this trip with
you so first of all Happy Thanksgiving
it'd have been my intent to have this
video be a review if not the entirety of
the Punisher at the very least the the
first half you know six or so episodes
of the Netflix series and then you'll
pick up with the latter half once I saw
the whole thing as I've done with the
last few sort of Netflix II shows that's
what I did with iron fist and defenders
and season two of stranger things and so
forth but I'm not gonna because I'm I
don't think I'm gonna finish this thing
and that's a first for me and I don't
know it's an odd enough experience I
kind of want to explain why the first
thing I will say is the Punisher is not
awful it's not even really bad it's
certainly not the worst Netflix show
that Marvel has put out it's miles
better than iron fist which is still the
low point but I was still able to get
through iron fist and yeah here's the
reason why I did not enjoy our in fist I
was giving it the benefit of the doubt
for the first few up so but by the
fourth episode I was realizing how bad
this was and that it was probably gonna
get worse
and it made me angry the thing about
anger is though anger can be energizing
and through a sheer force of spite I was
able to power through that show
basically just to justify screaming
about it afterwards so anger even to
some degrees disappointment can be
energized II can get you worked up he
fired up an but you know what doesn't
indifference boredom for episodes into
Punisher I am
bored I really bored like I it's almost
impossible for me to focus on this show
and not reach for my phone and I don't
think I have it in me to power through
this I could maybe make myself do it and
and if I was in a position where I made
my living doing this maybe I could even
justify it but I don't so when I'm as
unengaged as I am with the Punisher I
can't know that's ours I'm not gonna get
back and as I said I appreciate the
channel growth and everything else but
until I make a living off this I and
there's a limit to how much I'm prepared
to force myself to watch just cuz I
think I'm supposed to now this is
actually gonna MIT mark the first Marvel
property that I've bailed early on I
think the only other one would be ages
of shield but I did two and a half
seasons before I bailed on that and even
then it wasn't a decision oh I'm done
watching that I just I just faded on it
and then didn't catch up again so this
is this case of I'm I'm making the
decision that I'm going to do something
else it's a first and I guess as bought
by way of kind of a pseudo review ish
thing of the first four episodes Jon
Bernthal he's good in the part and there
are good moments and in fact the very
first episode pre-title sequence up
through the credits is awesome it's
really good and he's killing the guy in
the bathroom stall and he shoots a guy
across the Mexican border yes you know
it it starts off with that but then when
I actually sat down and catalogued how
many seriously plot relevant things had
gone on in the first four episodes there
was maybe an episode and a half
worth of actual plot that had happened
in four episodes this thing feels so
dragged out and that's a criticism I've
heard level that some of the Netflix
shows that are that aren't the defenders
before not and again I have issues with
the defenders but because they kept it
to eight episodes it was breezy at least
so and like I said I've heard this
criticism of other Netflix shows before
oh you know they dragged it out thirteen
episodes I'm not gonna ice to say that's
not true but all the other cases what I
ended up feeling was like there was one
or two specific episodes where I felt
that where I felt like there wasn't much
to this this is the filler episode this
is the padding episode it's it's like a
11 in about the first half of 12 of
Jessica Jones are very much that so you
know there's been things like that but
this was the first case where I felt
like the padding has been stretched out
across the season and again I understand
I only saw the first four episodes I saw
basically a quarter of the show and so
maybe it gets better after this but you
know four episodes paced the way this
thing is paced doing stuff that isn't
interesting or exciting or unexpected
and maybe maybe that's the big thing is
that there's nothing that's surprising
me about this I mean for God's sake it
it takes in basically three episodes to
get on board with micro micro was set up
at the end of daredevil season 2 why did
that take that long and I know you can
make an argument for you know a more
deliberately paced thing you know take
your time have some character beats go a
little bit more methodical and I'm not
against that as an approach I mean that
was very much the approach of Blade
Runner 2014 I and I enjoyed that movie
for the most part but this is the
Punisher and you opened with the
visceral year violence that the Punisher
is good for and then you you just stop
doing that you drop betting you go slow
and quiet and methought
you watch him talk with the wife of his
kind of maybe partner who he's torturing
half the dead look why why and again
none of its bad none of its cringy none
of it made me go oh dear god this is so
stupid the way that stuff and iron fist
did but I'm just sitting there going why
are we taking time with this why are why
are we tied up in this investigation for
this woman or man Dena what I can't even
remember that's how little impact the
show was leaving on me I can't even
remember these people's names
she is wrapped up in this investigation
of this thing in Kandahar which
coincidentally happened to involve Frank
and her entire plot is the very
definition of a we need to add time to
this story plot I mean there's no other
reason for her to be there I just I
can't I can't keep going with this I I
need to stop and you know what depending
on reactions comments responses if I get
an overwhelming wave of people that I
think are just trolling me who tell me
that it does legitimately turn around
and get really really good
I get notably different from how it's
been in the first four episodes later on
down the line maybe I'll watch the rest
but you know what I'm not gonna do I'm
not gonna force myself to power through
it to get a review out in a timely
manner the way that I have done with
these things I'm not doing that so if I
watch it at all it's gonna be spread out
over time and it honestly is probably
not even gonna happen and like I said
their take they're just taking so much
time and they set up Billy Russo and
they drop his name early on so I know
who he's gonna be I'm I haven't looked
up the reviews so I don't know if this
is true but I will bet money he does not
become jigsaw until though
endless of the season if that I will bet
you he gets taken down and supposedly
killed and it's like very end of the
last episode he emerges as jigsaw to set
up the next season I'm that's my bet
that's what my money is on because
that's the pacing of this whole thing
here's the thing you want to see come
get it come get it come get I'm not no
I'm not chasing this carrot at the end
of the stick because the road you've got
me running on chasing this thing is
boring I don't enjoy it it's boring it's
dull and again if you're enjoying the
punisher if you like it if you're really
into it if it's really doing it for you
wonderful good on you I'm happy for you
not me I gotta say no and it is a shame
because as I said Jon Bernthal is good
in this part he's especially good in
this interpretation of the character
it's a shame that I'm that I just I
can't bring myself to stick with this
it's just not grabbing me and if I were
to force myself to keep watching this at
this point I would be half watching it
because I wouldn't be able to stop
myself just messing around in my phone
the whole time so out of respect for my
self respect for my audience respect for
my own time hi guy I can't so that's my
rambling not really a review explanation
for why I'm probably not gonna talk
about the Punisher again thing about the
Punisher Kerr did you see more than the
first four episodes do you think I'm
just wasn't out I don't know whatever
you thoughts are respectful please drop
them down in the comments let's talk
about it don't forget to like subscribe
check me out on Twitter at Council of
geeks Cable listen to the Council of
geeks podcast that is available on Apple
podcast as well as stitcher radio I am
also one half of the punch like a girl
podcast that is a presentation of the
firewater podcast network Fire and Water
podcast comm links for all the stuff are
down below and until next time this
council is adjourned
Happy Thanksgiving
[Applause]
[Applause]